Yeah,
I have teenage boys and I started
investing with them when they were 12
years old.
So ideally the best time is when they're
teenagers.
I'm a big believer that those people who
have been exposed to investing at an
early age are going to be much more
comfortable with the whole process as
adults.
So ideally parents starch start teaching
their kids when they're teenagers,
you know,
open up a custodial brokerage account,
help them choose stocks and mutual funds
and let them be a part of the process.
But that's not always the case because
what we found from our studies is that
so many adults are not equipped to make
sound financial decisions.
Their parents didn't talk about it
there.
Um,
schools didn't teach them and so they're
not in a position to teach their own
kids.
So the second best place to start
investing is when you become in the
workforce when you're 20,
you know,
22 years old and he worked for a
corporation that offers a 401k.
In fact,
our studies show that that's really when
people begin to learn to invest,
but then it's up to the corporation to
provide financial education and literacy
and encourage their employees to take
advantage of this retirement vehicle
because young people have more time to
weather the ups and downs of the stock
market.
They're in a much better position to
take on more risk and you know with what
little more risk you get a little more
reward and that would be a reason to
take on more risk.
But again,
it really depends on your,
you know,
how much you can stomach it,
can you sleep at night when there are
bigger dips in the market?
Because if you do have a bigger
percentage of stocks in your portfolio
and we have a big downmarket that your
portfolio is going to react more so than
say if you had less stock and more
bonds.
But again,
over the long term history shows that if
you take on a little more risk,
you're going to get more return.
But keep in mind,
there is a sweet spot where there,
if you take on a little bit too much
risk,
you're not going to get that much more
return.
So consider,
you know,
at the very least I'm saying,
I'm going to say for a young person in
their twenties,
I would say,
and again,
it's very personal,
um,
at least 80% in a diversified stock
portfolio for their retirement account
or for those accounts that they know
they're not going to touch and they're
going to build upon over the year,
save for the next 40 years.
Yeah.